Italy's new right-wing government has
formally closed its ports to rescue
ships run by humanitarian groups that's
as three ships with more than a thousand
migrants on board remain stuck in limbo
off the coast of Sicily crews are
reporting worsening conditions on board
including the spread of sickness Italy's
interior Minister says ships would be
inspected at Sea before any further
steps are taken
the Balkan route taken by refugees into
the EU has not been in the spotlight for
some time but it's still busy and
getting busier EU officials recorded
more than a hundred thousand people
without documentation entering the block
from the Western Balkans in the first
nine months of 2022 Serbian visa rules
make it relatively easy to go from there
into the EU DW's Idris Ferry went to the
oberonauts camp near Belgrade
new arrivals at the obranova's camp they
have come from around the world here
they get a medical checkup or shower
something to eat and somewhere to sleep
hardly any plan to stay
we can take 200 people in our Emergency
Shelters on average they stay here for
around two weeks new people come but
people leave too and we have enough
capacity to accommodate them
are two of the few long-term residents
in the camp they both spend years on the
road and were tired of trying to cross
dangerous borders they both applied for
Asylum
and he'll give me this bag love so after
I decide that I want to rest here
because here my I'm a little bit
peaceful
bill has also settled here he fled the
war in Syria four years ago and can't go
back he's hoping to stay and work here
in Syria I was a carpenter and my father
was too he taught me the trade
when I left my country I planned to go
to Germany but then I decided to stay
here they gave me these machines a
workspace and everything I wanted to
make some sculptures and stay here to
work
foreign
is focusing on a different game that's
what they call the very serious business
of trying to cross the borders into the
EU
this is where it starts the spark near
belgrade's Main bus station is where
people prepare to travel to towns near
the borders with Croatia Hungary and
Romania EU countries that they'll pay
Smugglers thousands of dollars to get
across the frontier
which is a Belgrade lawyer and Refugee
activist what kind of problems did you
have with Bulgarian Police Department
beating our pupil with one more police
police yeah yes with the stick yeah
like so you were sleep you were searched
you were stripped to yeah
and where do you see a future what is
your plan our plans to go to the country
to peaceful country and we stay safe
they want to leave Serbia not because of
violence but because they see a better
chance of finding work in the EU Serbia
cannot stop them moving through says
kovachevich
Serbia cannot do anything so nobody can
do anything by themselves that's the
point the point is that
Western Balkan region or Balkan region
or European union or european region
should design
a response which is human rights and
Refugee or friendly that was the people
who would continue coming
they are fled from war poverty and
persecution the world over belgrade's
bus station is another step the Balkan
route is open and for many their best
hope this winter
for more in the current migration
situation in Europe we are now joined by
Gerald Canales a European migration
analyst and director of the European
stability initiative Think Tank and
former German government migration
advisor it's nice to have you in DW sir
is the balcon route really refugees best
entry into Europe right now
well it's very important to understand
two things the expression Balkan root
was a fantastic public relations success
of Victor Orban and the former Austrian
Chancellor Sebastian courts in 2016.
because what we are really dealing with
here is a region the Western Balkans
which is surrounded by the European
Union
it is true that a few people tunisians
Indians Burundi citizens can come to
Serbia visa-free and Serbia has said
that it will change this and align its
visa rules with the EU but all the
syrians Iraqis afghanis most of whom
you've also shown in your uh in your
report they don't come Visa free to the
Western Balkans they first have to enter
the European Union Greece or Bulgaria
and then from those countries they leave
the European Union to re-enter it
somewhere in the North and the basic
fact is that this year the number of
people who crossed from turkey and that
means from the whole Middle East into
the European Union irregularly is
extremely low
so the high numbers crossing the Western
Balkans are largely people who've been
in the EU for years in Greece who've
been treated very badly who don't see a
future there and who are trying to get
from one part of the EU to another part
of the EU there is no
strong increase of irregular migration
of Afghans or syrians into the European
Union this year or last year this route
is essentially a second chance for
refugees who have already fled into
Europe to make a better life for
themselves in Europe um the plight of
Ukrainian refugees has obviously
captured the world's attention perhaps
to the detriment of other Refugee crises
Ukraine aside where would you say is the
most challenging Refugee crisis the
world currently faces
well you you highlight a really
important point the reason countries
like Germany Austria or indeed many in
the European Union feeling under
pressure this year is because they have
accepted the highest number of refugees
in any year since the 1940s but
10 of 11 of those refugees have been
ukrainians who arrived who arrived
regularly they can cross the borders
without Smugglers they can simply come
across
the most important other route this year
and here we are talking about much much
lower numbers than the ukrainians but
still significant has been from Central
uh Northern Africa to Italy this year
already around 80 000 people have
crossed the Mediterranean it's a deadly
route the deadliest in the world it is a
route where the European Union has
relied on cooperation with Libya where
people are mistreated this is a shameful
Corporation but it is also a route where
a lot of people drown and now of course
the new Italian government is going to
try to repeat the policies of a previous
Italian government that has tried to
stop this by closing the ports to the
rescue ships this is not a policy that
will work and in fact the most important
humanitarian crisis at Europe's borders
today where most people die is there in
the central Mediterranean
and we're gonna have to leave it there
that uh Gerard Canal say European
migration analyst and director of the
European stability initiative Think Tank
many many thanks for your insights
yeah thank you